soup season meat Stove Top Stuffing
season ground turkey one egg one packet
of stove top stuffing and 3/4 a cup of
water it smells like Christmas and I'm
not mad about it roll some balls
meatballs obviously that's a massive
ball we need to cut back on the ball
size and into a 450° oven till they are
golden brown for the fastest tube of
life I've got some pre-bought bone broth
adding some extra protein with that a
little extra bullon for that super salty
kind of chicken soup like flavor and a m
of some of my favorite soup veggies
carrots parsnip and
celery so comforting and
deliciouso she's hot these meatballs are
also super delicious with canned
cranberry
sauce little bit of pepper on
top tiny bit of parsley that is winter
in a bowl my
friends yum oh they're so moist so juicy
and they taste like the holidays